I am Jeff Hale and I'm going to be
talking about making your python code a
little cooler with some blocks
so who am I I'm into Hawaiian shirts
hiking Ultimate Frisbee kind of right
out of Central Casting here for maybe
developer Advocates
um and uh I enjoy teaching about data
and in particular Python and data I've
written a lot about it especially at
medium so
um if you are interested in cloud
computing
um all kinds of different data topics
I've done done a good bit of that I've
done a good bit of teaching around
topics related to data science and data
Engineering also
uh and I I help organize events so I run
the data science DC Meetup co-organize
that that Meetup in DC so if you're in
the DC area ever
um come stop by when we got some events
going on
so prefect is an open source library and
there's a growing company behind it and
um when people you know ask while a
prefect app and say it's because it
solves some common pain points for lots
of folks with different data engineering
and machine learning engineering
workflows and it solves those elegantly
um so usually I'm talking to people
about coordinating their data flows
that's kind of the thing that we're
known for we have an orchestration uh
engine that makes it easier for you to
um orchestrate all of your different
data flows but
in addition to having this observation
and orchestration that that you might be
have seen with uh with prefect
um you can just put a few flow and task
decorators in your regular python code
turn into a deployment and then share it
with other people in your workspace
but today I want to focus mostly on
blocks uh and what these are
so first start with why right why would
someone want to learn about prefect
blocks and use them well number one it
makes it easier to collaborate with
co-workers especially co-workers who
maybe aren't quite as technical uh can
lead to fewer errors increase Security
in some cases easier extendability and
also save you some time and that's
something we all want a little bit more
of all right so what are these blocks
well really under the hood they're just
python objects but we've we've added a
little bit of magic to make a nice front
end for them and to let you host them on
either your own server with our open
source product or on our hosted solution
and we can have some access controls in
some cases when you want those too
so prefect blocks are served and stored
in a server database and if you do a pip
install prefect you will get a server
that you can run the Orion database
server and uh it can either sqlite right
out of the gate or if you want you can
put in postgres so you can do higher
workloads with it or you can use the
hosted prefect Cloud which has lots of
lots of capabilities and is free to get
started with
so there's an option and a problem that
data practitioners historically have to
either choose between a simple setup
experience with a low code data
integration tool or kind of flexibility
that comes with just when you're writing
Python and you can do everything with
all python pipeline
so you get a simple form potentially or
you have flexible pipe python
the question is why can't we have both
and if you recognize the little uh GIF
here this is the uh why not both but it
doesn't appear to play in this format
so uh blocks give you those choices so
that you have both of those options
it's kind of like a mullet you get a
structured form in front where people
can input information and you have
flexible code so you can use it in the
back
we can think of these as low code
connectors with a first class code
experience
so Best of Both Worlds here so how do
you get this awesomeness that's probably
the question you're asking yourself
right now
well it's just as easy as grabbing it
from pip uh python package manager with
a pip install Dash U prefect
and then you can create a block with a
HTML form interplay interface if you
want that's one option
and it's just throw a name into a form
field
and then a value for whatever your block
type is here I'm showing a secret block
and secret blocks are cool because they
use pedantic under the hood to
automatically obfuscate your uh your
value that you don't want anyone to see
and um
that's all it takes you put that in
there and now you can use this block
with a little code snippet that we even
provide in the UI that you can you can
use in your code in your python code and
again you see that the the uh the value
there is obfuscated
so that's option one to make a block
option two you can actually make it just
with python code
sorry my computer's Auto auto moving
forward here
uh you can just import the secret class
again remember blocks are just classes
uh under the hood so then you can import
it and uh save a value with it and then
save your block and have it available
and you can see it in your UI it's right
there available to use
all right so this prefect blocks give
you is flexible creation and editing so
let's talk about a potential use case
for those blocks so say you actually
want to share some cloud provider
configuration securely with some
teammates you got some different options
right first option is you could just
hard code your secret and uh there's a
lot of reasons you don't want to do this
although Bitcoin prices continue to fall
uh we still don't want people mining
Bitcoin uh on our AWS server because
they got access to our secret keys right
not not a good thing to do I'm not going
to say uh we have it all at some point
thought about doing a little hard coding
but not something you want to do
especially if it's going to get out onto
the web and get into Version Control
you could use environment variables so
these often work well but they do have
their shortcomings they can be viewable
in logs they're often tied to the
machine where you are so not quite a
perfect solution either
you could use a Secrets manager these
are popular but they do have their own
own issues they have vendor lock-in that
comes with them a lot of times often a
steep learning curve and they don't have
the configuration pieces that these
blocks the prefect offers have
so the fourth thing you could do is just
build your own custom secret manager uh
we all like a good challenge but this
sounds like quite a challenge right we
got to figure out all this configuration
you figure out how to deal with
encryption syncing things to a server
just not quite my idea of a weekend
project right it's it's a pretty a
pretty big project and something you
want to get right
so what you could use instead is a
prefect secret block so again obfuscated
pedantic secret string is what's being
used uh it's encrypted at rest and you
can even integrate it with your favorite
Secrets manager if you want to use
something like hashicorp Vault we have
an integration for that that you could
use
all right so let's uh switch gears here
for just a little bit and look at maybe
a historical context of these blocks so
way back 1791 Charles Babbage super
smart guy mathematician philosopher code
breaker he actually broke some ciphers
during the Crimean War he's an inventor
uh he invented the
ophthalmo ophthalmoscope and browse that
right and the cow catcher a lot of these
things didn't actually get designed uh
didn't actually have built in his
lifetime but he he did a lot of design
work on them so really a polymath and
you might have heard of his analytical
engine before this he designed a
Difference Engine and then an analytical
engine which is really the the thought
of oftentimes is the the first computer
never totally built and this is just a
part of it had many pieces uh that would
have been required to put it all
together but he designed what was was
the first modern computer
and it used a punch card system they
came from uh weaving looms uh and punch
cards this picture of a punch card is
actually taken from the 1970s I believe
my father actually used a punch card uh
programming system when when he was
first learning to use computers so
amazing this technology lasted for for
such a long time all the way from from
babbage's ideas uh up to the 70s
and then 1842 Ada Lovelace uses
babbage's ideas and does the becomes the
first computer programmer writes the
first program for a device that doesn't
really even exist yet which is totally
mind-blowing to me uh and just think
about that just trying to understand the
concepts of everything that's going on
and she's actually writing a program
that could could work with it
all right fast forward 1991
Guido van Rossum releases python to the
general public and that's part of why we
are all here talking today we we know
and love Python and I don't know about
you but it was really a first language I
really fell in love with in programming
land
oh I don't know what happened
the Google slide uh doesn't look like
this on my machine but in in our
presentation software here it appears to
uh so Streamlight gets released in 2018
and uh streamlit is I don't know if
you've used streamlit before but it's
really great for giving you a front end
no HTML CSS JavaScript necessary
python experience you can use their
little widgets and make a nice front end
for your data app it's very cool
so you don't need to have those skill
sets you don't have to learn so many
different things you have to learn
Ginger it can really make life easier
awesome 2018. Jeremiah lowen the CEO of
prefect gave a talk at Pi data DC so in
this Pi data ecosystem here called task
failed successfully where he introduced
the idea of prefect as an orchestration
engine
in 2019 prefect was released to the
General Public
and in 2022 we did a co-rewrite and
released prefect 2 a total ground up
rewrite and it includes blocks
so these blocks are similar to what's
what streamlet's doing in the sense that
they're allowing python developers to
build some HTML interface much more
easily you don't have to know how to do
all that and deal with all that
templating formatting
but it's different than Streamlight in
the sense that prefect blocks have this
configuration and information for reuse
and sharing it's more of like a back end
where streamlits really focused on on a
front-end user experience
so I think that's kind of interesting
interesting way to think about how those
those two are work together
so let's talk briefly about block types
here that prefect offers
so we have a whole bunch of different
block types right out the gate you can
have a string date time Json uh and a
secret that we've seen earlier
and then we have code storage block
types places where you can put your code
that will will run and be fetched at
runtime so GitHub super popular
AWS also and the other big cloud
providers Azure and Google Cloud Storage
foreign
types these are also all blocks using
that same same block idea we have a
Docker container or kubernetes job that
you can run so all of your code will run
in those containers
and then we have notification block
types if you want to be notified if your
code doesn't run well something goes
wrong or it goes goes right that's fine
you can be notified through email slack
Microsoft teams and just yesterday we
added twilio and pagerduty options so
lots of ways you can be notified
with how your your code is running
so let's zoom in for a second here just
talk about uh using an AWS S3 block to
store your code and then you can run
that code on a schedule
so it's super easy to make one of these
from the UI again this is totally open
source or you can use the hosted manage
version if you don't want to worry about
server type things
and you can just click on the add button
for that block type put in your block
name and your bucket path
and then uh if you are following good
practice and keeping it not open to the
public to get to your bucket you can put
in your access key ID and your access
key
and that's all it takes so a colleague
who doesn't ever want to touch python
code can add this configuration exactly
the configuration you need right there
in the UI so that opens up the range of
people who you can collaborate with
potentially
uh similarly with SNAP slack
notifications
uh you can you know do your work to go
and get your slack uh slack
um sign in information and make a web
hook URL and then just put it into a
block and then you have an opportunity
to share that information with other
people and be notified via slack when
something goes well or doesn't go well
with your code
foreign
types we want to make it easy for you to
extend the extend uh the interface and
and make what you need so uh there are
both python libraries that are out there
made by the community Integrations from
from all different things that we are
have 36 I think last I checked and
adding one every week or so uh so so
lots of those and if you want to make
one and contribute it back to the
community for people to use that's
awesome we love that
so there's just a range of of some of
those logos of the different block
opportunities that uh Integrations that
are out there that most cities have
blocks that we can use in one way or
another
so
um snowflake DBT gitlab hacks Great
Expectations few lots of names that you
use on lots of different projects right
if you want even more block types if
that's not enough you need more you can
go and create your own it says because
these blocks are just classes it's as
easy as just subclassing uh the core
block class so here's an example from
our docs of how you could make a little
Cube block if you if you so wanted and
then you would have uh the ability to do
prefect block register from the command
line and register that information with
the server and then voila
go to your UI and you will see that you
have a form available right there no
HTML CSS JavaScript needed and people
can fill in information and you can have
that available for your users
pretty cool huh
all right so uh if you're like working
on how do I do this get stuck on
something here we got docs a slack
Community with over 23 000 members in it
we have recipes common common use cases
that people have lots of blog posts that
we all write for for people we have doc
strings that are available everywhere
and anytime you do a dash dash help in
the CLI you'll get some help with how to
run a command so this is an example here
if you want to see like how do I can't
remember how to register a block if you
did prefect block register dash dash
help you would get information on
exactly what that does right in your
command line terminal
all right so let's turn briefly to
benefits of using blocks
so they take this guesswork out of
configuring your connection right you
might be like I know I got to put
something in you can download photo 3
and and whatever to to get a connection
to S3 or you can use a block and just
follow the form Fields filling in the
information that that's right there for
them
blocks can be used together you can have
multiple different blocks in the same
code so that's cool they're nestable
if you have a Docker registry block
where you have your your Docker image
hosted you can use that in your Docker
container so here's an example what that
looks like uh this is a little a little
part of the docker container block
there's options to just do a drop down
and select your Docker registry block
that you've already made so it's
reusable and nestable
so again these are versatile we saw that
the same core concept can be used in
lots of different ways with storage with
infrastructure to run your code with
notifications all those are options
these blocks are reusable right this is
nice we can we can use them over and
over you can use them in multiple
different flows
and that's great
and uh here's here's the best clip art
picture I could find uh workspace users
can share their blocks this is super
nice right teamwork someone is has
created some configuration you can share
that configuration across your workspace
with other users
a quote here from one of my colleagues
uh with blocks people don't need to Fork
prefect to extend it you can just go and
build some more blocks and that will
meet lots and lots of use cases so this
is meant to be a super easy way for
people to continue to hack on uh the
code and and do it in a way that doesn't
require
a lot of uh forking and and just more
more effort so very low friction way to
go and extend prefect
all right what else should you know
about prefect
we've been talking mostly about blocks
here but just switching hats for a
second to like I'm kind of interested in
how this could work for overall data
flow coordination well I'll let you know
that prefect has automatic logging just
right away automatic retries
uh scheduling notifications as we've
seen those before
caching it's nice to save you time when
you don't need to rerun something it
won't rerun easy async so this is nice
if you want to do things in in parallel
or in async it's fine we have a
collaborative UI
and you've seen that here with multiple
multiple ways you can get people
involved in your team
we have a hybrid model where your code
runs on your infrastructure it's
actually a patented model that we have
where we don't touch your code it runs
on your infrastructure you're just
sending metadata to the server so this
can be a big win for a lot of folks who
are in regulated Industries
um whether that's Healthcare Finance
Insurance things like that
uh and then we have all kinds of
Integrations as you've seen and one
thing we really strive for is
incremental adoption a lot of folks who
might think about trying to use some
kind of workflow orchestration tool you
really have to enter the the world of
that tool and learn a whole bunch of new
Concepts and change your code a whole
lot we've tried to make it so you have
to change your code as little as
possible so here's an example a very
very easy hello world right we're just
doing
um print hi there and with an if name
equals main block
if you want to make it a prefect flow so
that we can track it in the UI so you
can have all those nice benefits we
talked about it's as easy as saying at
flow with a flow decorator that's all it
is so import that decorator and just add
that to your function and now you've
automatically got logging right there if
you if you run that file
if you want retries that's as easy as
passing retries and some integer we
tries equals some integer to your to
your decorator there so super again
super quick you don't have to change
your python code in order to get these
benefits
if you want notifications that's as easy
a couple ways you can do it but one way
it's super easy go into the UI and just
say when a flow reaches a certain status
I want to see this uh be alerted in this
way
so prefect Cloud I mentioned this is the
hosted option it's got a free tier lots
of goodies you can always use that but
if you're an Enterprise customer who
wants to have Enterprise features uh we
have have paid service for that too
and in the UI whether it's self-hosted
or hosted on prefect Cloud we've got all
kinds of things you can track about how
your uh your code is run
so mention the hybrid model earlier
again big idea here is that your code
runs on your infrastructure not on ours
so that's uh that's uh something we're
very proud of
and just like hey I was just getting
used are people doing this uh absolutely
we have recently passed over 10 000
GitHub stars and prefect has now run
over 2 billion tasks the prefect cloud
has so pretty huge number of of use uh
uses there
all right and if you'll permit me just
one more blocks metaphor here as we're
wrap things up the block and tackle
system not something you see as much
every day today but very popular back in
the day included the system of pulleys
and ropes right and gave you a
mechanical advantage it was a force
multiplier so uh here if you use 25
Newtons of force you actually get the
benefit of 100 Newtons of force because
you're using this this pulley system
so similarly the prefect blocks make it
easier to build great things it's a
force multiplier
all right so again final like why use
these blocks you can create them with
either the HTML form or with code your
option so different people can do
different things there you can use a man
in your code and should result in fewer
errors right you're not going to have a
typo there on
um you know what that field was that you
needed they are secure composable
nestable versatile reusable shareable
and easily extendable
all right so encourage you all here to
think about like huh how can I use some
kind of prefect block idea on my next
project how could this be helpful to me
and with that uh oh perfect timing we
gotta five and a half minutes for
questions
any questions about prefect blocks or
anything else
um thank you very much Jeff we are very
delighted to have you at Pi data Global
so if anyone has question so you can go
on with your question now
thank you
so you can type in your question is
going to we are going to see it
foreign
if not that's fine too
anyone who has uh thinks of something
there they want to ask about feel free
to jump into uh the prefect slack and
ask a question over there again we have
over 23 000 community members there so
happy to to answer any questions uh
awesome Joseph just appreciate your
doing some typing here we will wait for
your typing
foreign
I got a question here from JD can you
speak to how prefect 2 differs from uh
prefect so presumably from from prefect
one uh yeah so prefect one uh like I
mentioned came out to General
availability in 2019 and prefect 2 was
released General availability just this
summer
so one of the things that we learned
um there's a number of ways that they're
different it was a total total rewrite
from things we learned from version one
and one of the things that we learned
was that having a rest API for folks to
interact with was
avoided a lot of problems and and made
everyone's situation a little a little
more
um
uh enjoyable so instead of a graphql
back end interface uh we have a a rest
API that you can use with it
um we have a better better speed and
currency kind of options uh with prefect
2 we have we have a new event a new
events driven observation
um work that is being finished being
added to a continual attitude but that
we're about to release some big things
on here in coming weeks so uh that's
that's pretty exciting should really
give you a much easier way to view
everything that's happening in your data
stack with prefect we're really excited
about that
um we hear from customers and users all
the time that they just really like the
experience of prefect 2 which is how how
Snappy everything is and and how much it
can handle uh so so that's nice
um and from like a very
um syntactic level uh you're now able to
just use decorators for things like
flows instead of
um
uh instead of having to use like with
context block so that's like some of
those ergonomic type things are are nice
and things that we really enjoy so uh
prefect 2 is getting getting all the the
attention these days and we're making it
making it uh as best we can yep try and
get a high level answer on what is
perfect
or is it not like Jenkins or airflow
yeah but I can get a high level answer
which is not like a Jenkins or an
airport yeah so uh there the uh airflow
is is more more similar
um Jenkins kind of serves a different
purpose here but
um uh our Jeremiah lowen our original
our CEO originally was uh on the the
core maintaining group of uh of uh
Apache airflow and really want to try to
get the organization to move in a very
data data flow first kind of Direction
and uh kind of have a view of the world
where people should be able to not have
to think in a whole not learn a whole
bunch of new Concepts would be able to
just use kind of their basic python code
that they have and change it as little
as possible and
um decided to go and start prefect to
kind of bring that to life so we hear
from
[Music]
um